faire le même métier à 24 heures sur 24
sur l'autre au bout d'un moment ça
devient invivable c'est-à-dire que vous
étiez effectivement
collé parce que j'ai tout ensemble mais
oui
sur le plateau de tout le monde a parlé
alors on va commencer avec vous slown de
votre vrai nom Chantal Richard vous êtes
né le 16 avril 1952 à Orléans votre mère
avait été mariée de force très jeune ce
qui fait qu'elle divorce quand vous avez
8 ans et que vous n'avez pas beaucoup
connu votre père en fait quand votre
mère divorce toute la famille lui tourne
le dos sauf un ami d'enfance amoureux
d'elle depuis toujours qu'il a recueille
avec ses cinq enfants
cet homme fils d'ouvriers devenu artiste
de cirque avait longtemps été partenaire
du clown Fratellini et finalement il
initie toute la famille au spectacle
absolument c'est ça c'est au même âge
que vous commencez à chanter vous serez
soliste dans une chorale et choristes
avec votre sœur pour raymoncia
l'inventeur de l'accordéon plat en forme
de clavier absolument c'est vrai avec ma
sœur Pascal Richard fatigant parce que
on chantait des quatre heures six heures
d'affilée à l'époque c'était des balles
ou des soirées privées mais c'est le
meilleur métier je pense pour apprendre
alors vous composez aussi dès l'âge de
13 ans un opéra rock intitulé Le
Cavalier d'Opale dont nous reparlerons
et vous deviendrez également
marionnettiste pendant 17 ans
marionnette en lumière noire on les
fabriquait la nuit et le jour j'allais à
l'école
mais c'était la passion
alors vers 18 ans accompagné par votre
sœur Pascal vous montez à Paris pour
tenter votre chance vous travaillez
comme chanteuse d'orchestre et choristes
pour Gérard Lenorman Herbert Léonard
Carlos Dave et une débutante qui
s'appelait Céline Dion oui le premier
album de Céline elle avait 13 ans et
avec ma petite sœur nous avons fait les
cœurs dans son premier album et la voix
c'était c'était incroyable qu'on avait
pris le un choc terrible à l'époque et
ça m'étonne pas que les films carrière
comme ça ça s'est passé assez facilement
quand même très vite avec ma petite sœur
on a pas hésité à cogner aux portes des
studios on n'a pas hésité à travailler
même présenter aller chanter de faire
des cœurs gratuitement pour qu'on nous
écoute et ça a pas été gratuit très
longtemps après
alors voilà alors ensuite vous faites
partie de différents groupes amours
zigzag la Bande à Basile et vous en
créer un qui s'appelle Ministar dans ce
tour de la terre voilà et c'est juste
après sont très Jean-Pierre absolument
jean-Pierre Savelli alias Peter donc
vous êtes né le 18 mai 1949 à Toulon
votre père Carlo Coty était chanteur de
charme dans les années 30-40 et c'était
un peu un rival de Tino Rossi au départ
oui le concurrent direct de Tino plus
jeune que lui mais voilà il arrive de
Corse comme lui alors quand vous
n'essaie il m'a un peu sa carrière entre
parenthèses oui papa a décidé de
descendre de Paris de revenir un petit
peu sur Toulon on vivait avec la famille
et de s'occuper un petit peu de de ma
soeur et de moi alors votre mère femme
au foyer ensuite comptable oui alors
vers 12-13 ans vous commencez à chanter
à jouer de la guitare vous commencez
également les concours de chant et vous
faites un concours de chant à l'âge de
17 ans où vous êtes repéré par Fernand
Sardou le père de Michel Sardou en me
remettant le prix il me dit tu es déjà
prêt pour faire quelque chose vidéo mais
vous inquiétez pas dans quelques années
je vous enverrai mon 45 tours
vous rejoignez votre sœur qui est
esthéticienne et là vous devenez
coiffeur pour dame oui beau métier très
beau métier plus l'école pas du tout non
je joue au rugby déjà ça allait pas avec
voilà les entraînements tout ça puis non
mais je m'ennuyais à l'école donc voilà
j'ai mes juste une chose c'est
l'histoire et ça suffisait pas voilà
donc ça vous empêche pas de continuer
votre carrière de chanteurs et de
guitariste on les orchestre de balle le
weekend enfin bon des petits orchestre
de 4 musiciens et jusqu'à 10 musiciens
et on allait à travers la France pareil
comme Chantal alors poussé par la
famille et les amis vous quittez Toulon
à l'âge de 20 ans et là votre père il
prend la déesse et vous prenez tous les
deux la route pour Paris c'est lui qui
vous amène à Paris en fait ben oui il
m'a dit c'est le seul endroit où tu peux
faire quelque chose parce qu'on me dit
que tu es déjà prêt pour faire ce métier
c'est Paris alors votre père vous dépose
à Pigalle et il vous dit tu vas voir
c'est un quartier très vivant oui il m'a
dit vivant pas chaud il m'a dit vivant
et c'était vivant c'était extraordinaire
de vivre là pendant quelques mois
j'ai vu des belles choses
notre Père qui vous conseille de prendre
contact avec Georgette plana qu'il avait
connu pendant la guerre et elle vous
donne rendez-vous au carrefour Pleyel et
vous vous comprenez ça le Pleyel en vous
l'attendez en vain évidemment puisque
vous n'avez pas le portable
à un moment vous voyez écrit production
Michel Legrand vous dites je vais monter
et c'est la maman de Michel Legrand qui
vous ouvre la porte quoi Raymonde
Legrand faut dire que dans les
orchestres dont je faisais partie à
l'époque dans le midi je chantais déjà
du Michel Legrand et pour moi de voir
son nom je me suis dit c'est pas
possible il faut pas que je loupe ça
voilà c'est incroyable alors elle vous
fait rencontrer son fils donc Michel
Legrand et 6 mois plus tard il vous
signe un contrat il vous écrit un
premier 45 tours qui s'appelle un goût
de soleil de pomme et de miel une très
belle chanson qui sera reprise par
sarahone et Samy Davis junior quand même
oui deux jeunes chanteurs américains
j'ai pas souffert à Paris j'ai pas fait
les galères en 1972 vous gagnez le Grand
Prix de d'or à Antibes avec ciel c'est
important à l'époque la rose d'orontine
là vraiment dans la Pinette de
Juan-les-Pins quand ils ont commencé à
dire troisième prix deuxième prix
premier prix j'ai dit bon mais j'ai rien
vu d'un coup il y a eu Grand Prix donc à
l'époque produit par le grand et Eddy
Barclay avec ciel puis ça m'a permis de
continuer alors en 1975 vous avez le
premier rôle dans la Révolution
française de Claude Michel Schoenberg et
Alain Boublil date importante aussi dans
votre carrière Schonberg ou Bill qui
vient de me voir qui en tournée avec
Claude François en 74 qui me disent on
monte le opéra rock est-ce que ça te
dirait de faire quelque chose avec nous
oui oui je me retrouve avec le premier
rôle à chanter des chansons fantastiques
au début des années 80 nous interprétez
des génériques de séries télé Goldorak
Albator XOR etc et c'est là que vous
rencontrez Chantal alors
en 1983 vous êtes tous les deux au
Palais des Congrès vous dans le studio a
et vous dans le studio B et vous
Jean-Pierre on vous dit tu devrais
écouter la chanteuse dans le studio d'à
côté elle se débrouille bien et là vous
enregistrez une chanson extraite de
votre opéra rock justement le chevalier
d'Opale avec 60 musiciens la productrice
la tes propriétaires du Palais des
Congrès me dit il y a une blonde
tout en noir elle chante super il faut
que tu écoutes parce que toi qui aime
les duos qui aime faire des toujours des
voix des cœurs et tout et voilà
rencontre alors coup de foudre amoureux
et artistique vous décidez de travailler
ensemble sur une chanson et vous faites
ma vie avec toi ta vie avec moi mais il
vous faut une face B
il vous fait un autre titre oui voilà en
studio ça a été décidé en studio et le
titre évidemment ses besoins de rien
envie de toi la face B devient un tube
énorme qu'il a écrit cette chanson j'ai
fait la musique ah ouais deux heures
pour la fête l'affaire et mets tomber
d'un coup en un quart d'heure c'est
incroyable c'est comme ça une mélodie
c'est ça peut être je suis plus une
mélodie ce qu'une musicienne et voilà
c'est tombé alors Bernard et Sardy
l'orchestrateur me dit ben tu fais un
titre rythmé puisqu'on a un slow en face
a fait nous un titre rythmé et puis
voilà tout est descendu et dans la nuit
Jean-Pierre avec Marie Casanova moi j'ai
trouvé devant devant la fenêtre le titre
besoin de rien envie de toi j'ai appelé
ma copine Marie Casanova qui est Corse
comme moi et on a fait le texte tous les
deux et puis il faut dire que ma vie
avec toi tu es avec moi ça plaît slow
pour Anne voilà
Jean-Pierre et Chantal
j'ai mis le doigt sur
comme j'ai du sang irlandais dans les
veines voilà heureusement que tu as mis
le doigt sur pour
oui
alors Pinterest loport
besoin de rien envie de toi chanson
énorme qui restera numéro au top 50
pendant 8 mois ça a été la première
chanson du Top 50 en fait quand ils
l'ont créé c'est notre chance numéro du
top naissance de canal et on nous dit
vous êtes les numéros du Top 50 et là on
a plus rien compris ça a été
extraordinaire
espagnole allemande c'est bien marré et
puis c'est formidable de faire son
métier comme on a toujours voulu le
faire c'est ça qui est formidable alors
c'est un triomphe évidemment comment on
réagit les gens de notre entourage alors
votre famille très fier les deux parce
qu'on est très famille tous les deux et
pour eux c'était voilà c'est un conte de
fée et ils étaient heureux pour lui très
heureux surtout de dire ils ont quand
même un passé musical moi j'avais vendu
quelques millions de disques aussi avec
des enfants avec des génériques mais bon
et puis là à deux un nouveau duo il y
avait plus Stone et chardettes donc un
nouveau duo le brun la blonde tiens ils
sont amoureux voilà vos relations avec
les médias ça s'est bien passé en
général
moi je vous dis honnêtement beaucoup de
gens qui avaient refusé
ah tiens tel télé non pas pour
Jean-Pierre c'est pas ça il y a des gars
qui m'ont dit tu vas te venger là et
nous on se parlait tout se vengers de
quoi on va leur dire quoi on veut pas
faire votre télé on était ravis on a
fait des milliers de kilomètres trois
galas c'est pas concert trois gars dans
la nuit chantal a eu beaucoup de
problèmes physiques parce que le sommeil
et tout c'était pas évident mais j'étais
très menu à l'époque bon depuis j'ai pas
peur et donc voilà c'était mais c'était
un moment
magique on a pris de revanche sur
personne alors l'argent j'ai gagné leur
monde argent cette histoire si vous
étiez vous compositrice et vous parliez
non oui bien sûr puis des concerts les
Ghana mais franchement oui bien sûr bien
sûr
85 il y a eu des rentrées d'argent ça
s'aime voilà c'était très très bien j'ai
mis un peu de côté oui oui on a mis de
côté oui un peu à Toulon un peu en Corse
et vous aussi moi j'ai mis plutôt dans
les chevaux
[Rires]
quel a été le meilleur moment de cette
époque rappelle-toi ce qui était
formidable parce qu'on est en train de
faire notre album chez Bernard et Sardy
et le non-producteurs nous avait dit
venez il y a un dîner avec la maison de
disque il faut absolument venir je sais
que vous êtes fatigué mais il faut venir
et en fait on est arrivé on a ouvert la
porte du restaurant et il y avait tout
le staff de
l'époque et ils ont tous ils sont levés
avec le champagne ils sont applaudis
parce que de 2020 jours on était passé
en une semaine à combien 27000 il y a eu
des pointes il nous le montrer 40 000
et là personnellement ça a été un
souvenir un choc on se demandait ce qui
se passait pourquoi tout le monde était
là et on a appris qu'on avait quadruplé
même plus les ventes en deuxième 45
tours vous devez sortir pour tous ceux
qui vont s'aimer mais Jean-Pierre refuse
écoutez moi franchement ça c'est une
histoire entre Chantal et les
producteurs peut-être c'est des choses
qui n'ont pas été bien honnêtes là ils
parlait un peu à Chantal il parle un peu
à moi
là les frères célib je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas été très très honnêtes alors
je sais pas moi j'ai jamais je ne vois
pas en tant que chanteur interprète
c'est pas moi le producteur dire je ne
veux pas je ne veux pas alors à la place
de pour tous ceux qui vont s'aimer vous
sortez c'est la vie de château avec toi
moi j'ai vu que on sortait c'est la vie
de château avec toi une chanson que
j'avais fait avec Marie Casanova et
c'est comment j'aurais pu dire moi par
rapport à chaton elle était à égalité je
vois pas j'étais pas j'avais pas de
l'affinité plus qu'elle je crois pas
avec des producteurs en tout cas la
suite a montré que on a arrêté notre
contrat et la scène qui reste avec des
frères Scénic c'est qui c'est Chantal
Richard moi je suis pas resté donc il
s'entendait très très bien ensemble donc
cette histoire je l'ai entendu deux
trois fois et moi j'ai toujours dit je
n'y suis pour rien voilà alors le
problème c'est que la chanson dépassera
pas la 43e place du Top 50 si cela c'est
un peu la désillusion derrière un tube
qui est énorme il fallait attendre
d'abord on était fatigué il fallait
attendre et prendre son temps voilà mais
je pense qu'ils ont voulu vraiment comme
beaucoup de choses en 45 tours après on
fait un album voilà c'est une maison
normale bon si on avait entendu un an on
avait pris notre temps peut-être que les
mais bon avec des si on fait pas la vie
alors à ce problème artistique s'ajoute
un problème amoureux parce que dès le
début de votre relation Jean-Pierre
devient annoncer la couleur vous aviez
dit que vous ne renonceriez pas votre
liberté effectivement vous avez d'autres
aventures et vous vous en avez souffert
un peu oui j'en ai souffert je m'en
cache pas parce que je suis très entière
et romantique et le duo tout ça à la
fois professionnel et amoureux et voilà
que Jean-Pierre
c'était sérieux mais moins sérieux mais
j'avais annoncé la couleur et tout ça
parce que avec ce métier là déjà un duo
qui chante ensemble et tout si en plus
voilà la preuve a été que voilà moi ça a
été très
aussi alors Chantal vous dites nous
avions deux caractères très forts et
c'est vrai qu'elle est souvent des
courts-circuits entre nous qui pouvaient
se terminer en clash moi et puis des
gens qui ont pas été là pour arranger
trop les choses on n'a jamais un
médiateur entre nous et vous Jean-Pierre
vous dites faire le même métier avec 24
heures sur 24 sur l'autre au bout d'un
moment ça devient un village c'est à
dire que vous étiez effectivement
de ma liberté pour le sport pour plein
de choses et tout ça et puis voilà et
puis après un moment donné c'est vrai
que Chantal elle a craqué et c'était dur
quoi voilà la rupture est inévitable
c'est donc un cycle duo s'arrête en fait
c'est à votre rupture amoureuse vous
vous êtes anéanti vous partez au Canada
pour essayer de vous reconstruire à ce
moment là
et vous surmonterez votre chagrin
d'amour vous retrouverez quelques années
plus tard tous les deux
voilà on nous a rappelé pour faire des
choses des producteurs indépendants
est-ce que vous voulez rechanter
ensemble moi le goût de chanter ben
voilà c'est ça qui est le plus important
voilà on a mis des choses au point on a
fait des choses chanson ensemble et le
producteur indépendant c'est le papa de
ma fille
que tout recommence
c'était imagine que tu recommences même
pour nous deux quoi c'est une chanson
d'amour qui était très sympa mais ça a
pas accroché alors aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous êtes nostalgique de l'époque de
de votre tube énorme besoin de toi non
si ce n'est qu'à l'époque on avait 24
ans de moins
il ne s'agit de ça alors je faisais 45
kg donc j'étais toute menue
referiez pas pareil Chantal je ne serai
pas sortie avec Jean-Pierre pour pour
garder un côté très professionnel
et qu'il n'y ait pas ses sentiments qui
étaient très forts chez moi qui ont tout
mélangé ça c'est important et ça ça oui
mais refaire le duo oui faire quelque
chose contre ça l'amour ça se commande
pas
mais c'est vrai mais peut-être que il
aurait fallu que que je sois plus forte
j'ai été trop fait peut-être à l'époque
fragile pas faible
et vous alors si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
choisir Paris comme ville qui m'a
éloigné depuis 40 ans de ma famille
ma maman à 93 ans aujourd'hui mais elle
me manque je la vois pas trop et puis
pareil mon père je l'ai pas vu partir
quoi voilà ça ça ce métier m'a bouffé
beaucoup de choses m'a apporté
énormément de joie aucun problème mais
bon ça vous a coupé de vos bases quoi
alors le jour vous allez mourir sont
elles que vous voulez qu'on écrive sur
votre tombe
passionné
et oui Jean-Pierre
papa maintenant on va pouvoir faire un
duo ensemble c'est bien c'est très
heureux de rallumer la lumière soit vous
merci merci et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu